that's the blessing I think
of going through life and getting wisdom
because America is a version of that the
more I leave the country you okay we're
the
we're the the Adolescent the Adolescent
of Earth of the all the countries yeah
and I take when I go to certain places
I'm not I'm here as a black man when I
go to a certain places I'm in America
and like American is the first state
ever the first one that's how identity
identify you but we've done things in
other countries right that if we knew we
wouldn't be proud of but as an American
I still take ownership of that and still
be like we number one you know I mean
but you think there are things like we
should be embarrassed by like bad
practices
um
like there's a bit of Shame
associated with it yeah we're not the
we're not the best it's just stuff we
don't know about right yeah we have good
PR yeah we got a good PR to ourselves
good propaganda you know I mean well the
the propagators of the propaganda are
the people yeah so but we all get a
radio yeah we do get we get our version
of the radio but it's a blessing it's a
blessing in that but it's still like oh
it's like when you see that the video
games from other countries and we're the
bad guys but here we play video games
and we shoot at other right people that
speak other languages we don't even know
where they're from right but then you
see them wearing American flags and the
kids are like get them
I didn't know that was a thing they were
video games video games it's the
opposite and it's like but aren't those
where are those games being made because
Call of Duty and all that stuff that's
also part of propaganda by the way when
I say propaganda but that's what I'm
saying they gotta sell as a business
person they gotta sell
to the Russians too who the Russians
gonna shoot
Racers ain't gonna shoot Russians who
are you shooting they got to shoot us
they're looking they're looking at the
map and being like let's change it yeah
let's swap it up is that is it I've seen
footage of a game where we we are the
bad guys like we invaded them and I'm
like
I'm like oh [__] you know right but it
is what it is I've never thought about
that and it's crazy
yeah my friend because my first time to
the Middle East that's when I first time
experiencing being an American would
tell me about that and uh where were you
I went to Bahrain in 2006 uh to do
stand-up and
um you know being in that that's not a
place I guess a lot of it's more
Africans golden Americans when you pull
your passport out in this blue it's like
an extra stair like really like like and
it could be it's For Better or For Worse
but luckily because of rap music is for
the better
the hip-hop family yeah okay yeah
because that that take that has taken us
worldwide but some Africans and other
countries have bad reputations
okay so it's almost a little relief but
then it's like wait are you one of the
uh
when they think you're African if they
might think you're African there's a set
of stereotypes no that's a set of
stereotypes yeah whatever I guess I
don't want to propagate them but they're
bad they're it's nice all good and there
are places like like it's the same like
you know if you hear a Nigerian scam
here yeah and but like Nigerian prince
yeah or Nigeria
is that run by Nigerians that would be
funny if they're if you're a Nigerian
doing a scam and they're like let's give
Nigeria a shout out yeah let's make the
prince from our country nothing else
will be traceable back to us but a
little shout out to Nigeria everybody
princess in Nigeria and everybody lose
their wallet and need uh because that
seems like a scam not made by Nigerians
to me but I got Nigerian friends and
they like they do it
the scam they they might uh you know
somebody wrote my homeboy one time
and then he he was like this ain't gonna
work I'm not Jerry and then he was like
oh well look we looking for credit card
information and all type of stuff you
know what I mean so okay so that is okay
that's not a thing but it's a it's a
serious thing but I'm an outsider so
okay are you Nigerian no well DNA wise
DNA no I know you were born here yeah
but I'm I didn't know I thought I would
be like got her I was gunning and stuff
like that and we got an idea 23andMe you
did it it was like Nigeria and I was
like I called all my Nigerian friends
and I was like
yeah yeah you know because the first
time I remember going to a Nigerian
house
it was like walking into a
racist person house almost
the way this family was being they were
one of the uncles who's from Nigeria
because
I'm American oh he was racist to you
yeah he was like well you know who's
like jokingly who let this white man
wolf in the house really because that's
the day I found out that's when I
stopped calling myself African-American
too and I was like oh it's a separate
thing because they're African-Americans
right I'm black you know what I mean
right but it was explaining my homeboy
was like oh he Nigerian who don't know
he's Nigerian but then I later found out
we're we're all a lot of us are mixed
blood that's what I heard we're not pure
African so and we're we're a little bit
more
uh trained to the American lifestyle
hence the white man Wolf coming okay
yeah so and then I did my DNA test and I
found out that I'm Nigerian and Sierra
Leone and like Congolese and like all
these
things but then I'm like oh I'm mixed
with
people that people don't like who got
with the bad reputation should I say
um Nigerian who got bad reputations
um uh 15 European German who got bad
reputation French you know how they are
uh
uh Irish okay
um and then I'm gonna smidget Iranian
too and I'm like damn it's a lot of
[__] going on in my in my DNA and
before the internet that's all there was
yeah but the discovery of it is like I'm
like well we Pat when we like passed
around it's just a thing I'm still
trying to figure out like how did these
all these mixtures right but I know my
name is like Irish and Celtic Welsh and
stuff like that you okay so all right so
there's lots of different
it's interesting how different groups
are racist to other groups so you're
saying everybody's to me Africans are
racist towards Well everybody's a lack
of sales because East and West not as a
whole but this house you went into tell
me what the East and West are have
issues some underlying issues East
African West Africa yeah have some
underlying issues right this is I was
actually just thinking about this not as
a movie but I was like white people
right that are xenophobic and racist and
aggressively nationalistic right like
the race War people let's say let's jump
150 years after a horrible thing into
the future now it's just white people
and this weird like I'm saying like just
play it out what do you want to happen
spiritually go to the past go to win or
go to the past when when the Irish
landed or when the Italians landed
that's my point like you just find
another way race to me is just the
laziest because it's overt it's it's a
skin color and it's a culture and it's a
food and it's a different clothing and
all these things that are so obvious so
what we really don't like is
separateness and and unknown I I'm not
I'm saying obviously can go deeper than
that yeah but if it all is just all
white people and and your plan worked
and now it it does look like 1941 or
whatever even though obviously there
were diverse different groups there too
but let's say it's all white people
you'd still find another way it happens
it's Irish that's my Protestant it's
Catholic it's left-handed that's my
that's what I that's my observation it's
like even because I I had the joke about
it's people you don't like in your own
family and they look like you that's
well that's it just might wear glasses
they make they macaroni and cheese a
little different you know give me when
they use ghee instead of butter right
right [__] them that's what I'm saying
is there's some you can say whatever you
want there's something going on that we
have something about ourselves that we
hate yeah and it's so uncomfortable to
hold on to it that I project it on to
anyone yeah and even if they're other
people that look like me for me of
course they look like me it's almost
easier because you know they're dumb
[__] just like me I'm like look at this
dumb [__] filled with rage filled with
hate filled with shame filled with guilt
and then I'd start what I'm saying is
but that's what makes being an adult
[__] because you know now that everybody
got the [__] in them so the older you
get you really just don't care about
nothing when you get back in that phase
again because you know like the world is
full of [__]
you you're saying getting to a certain
age and admitting and yeah pretending
yeah and coming to grips with that
coming to grips you got it's coming to
grips with like your your part of you
that's full of [__] yes like when my
girl say I'm in mature and I'm like okay
uh thanks for the discovery I'm gonna
play with this yeah I mean yes and to
come in the grips with that
and the brain is something peaceful
about it of course but then you have you
accept that in other people there's
something peaceful about that
precisely yep when you remove the burden
of knowing everything for yourself you
can relax and other people don't need to
know everything either and then we're
all just kind of swimming around the
same soup
[Music]